flagged Ripper's those funny little
emitters that sort of stand up and wave
hi
what's the point of those help Rika
steel here the sprinkler warehouse bro
let's talk flag drippers
[Music]
[Applause]
flagged Ripper's are non pressure
compensating which is a bit of a
misnomer all emitters are somewhat
pressure compensating what non pressure
compensating generally means is that you
shouldn't use it on a slope of say five
feet or more no slope save your money
and buy non pressure compensating
emitters such as flag emitters because
pressure compensating emitters cost for
of course other than their price tag
there's no real downside to using
pressure compensating back two flags
this little thing on top is used to
disassemble the flag so you can clean it
out should it become clogged which can
happen especially if there's a lot of
minerals in the water
despite their resemblance of little
inline valves turning the flag on top
does not regulate water flow the flags
are often color-coded depending on
gallons per hour the colors of the ones
I'm using today are black for one gallon
green for two and red for four that may
change depending on the manufacturer
often flag emitters are rated in litres
per hour
in that case just remember that there
are roughly four liters to the gallon
flag emitters are perfect for a low
pressure system like a gravity-fed
system where some other emitters may not
work so well let's install some in our
system we can install it directly on our
mainline like this
or we can run some micro tubing like
this and install it where it's needed a
stake will help direct the water where
we want it if you do install it this way
remember this piece of micro tubing is
now regulated by this flag emitter in
this case it's two gallons per hour you
don't want to install another emitter on
the end of this because you've already
regulated the pressure back here you can
also attach micro tubing to the barbed
like this remember sprinkler Warehouse
has everything for your irrigation needs
so that your trees lawns flowerbeds and
Gardens are lush and beautiful and if
you have any questions about our
products give us a call or chat with one
of our superb customer service agents on
sprinkler warehouse.com they really know
their stuff and they'll get you squared
away please subscribe to our YouTube
channel to get the most out of our
user-friendly shop and compare Web Store
for sprinkler warehouse I'm Alfred
Castillo your sprinkler warehouse pro
[Music]